borrarlas despojarlas y someterlas desde
la llegada del talibán al poder no han
parado de restringir los derechos de las
mujeres al estudio a trabajar al espacio
público
la última prohibición privarlas de
elaborar para la organización de
Naciones Unidas de las seiscientas
mujeres que trabajan para la institución
en Afganistán cuatrocientas son
nacionales un personal sumamente valioso
para la misión de la ONU en ese país
es una gran violación de los derechos de
las mujeres y las implicaciones No solo
son aplicables en Afganistán porque es
un presidente y no podemos aceptarlo ni
en Afganistán ni en ningún otro país las
mujeres son absolutamente esenciales
para todos los aspectos de nuestro
trabajo y la prestación de servicios en
Afganistán
la organización multilateral fue el
último santuario para las afganas desde
la secretaría general hicieron un
llamado resaltando que el personal
femenino es fundamental
lo que está claro es que no podemos
hacerlo sin las mujeres las mujeres son
la columna vertebral de nuestras
operaciones humanitarias estoy tratando
de obtener el desglose por género Pero
obviamente dada la sociedad y la cultura
se necesitan mujeres para brindar ayuda
a las mujeres
por lo tanto nos mantenemos en estrecho
contacto y nos relacionamos con las
autoridades de facto
en diciembre pasado el Ministerio de
economía prohibió a las ong presentes en
el país que las contraten quienes pueden
y tienen los medios huyen hacia Pakistán
o hacia Europa naciones como Dinamarca y
Suecia les otorgan asilo Sin condiciones